[Music]
to all our amazing fans the truth is we
are here for you we got to thank you for
10 years of support and inspiration the
reason we're here
thank you for 10 years of the greatest
cosplay
[Music]
standing in those long lines for Hall
age reading the comics after you saw the
movie Twitter fights and it's all been
leading up to this thank you yes thank
you so much thanks for being so
incredible we couldn't have done any of
this without you the entire time I knew
him he only ever had one go
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
danos
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a Dennis once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan tears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good Wow
the end is near
and um
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as whole things should be
I hope they remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man
[Music]